today i will be presenting on the topic
financial data forecaster that is the
time series forecasting of stock market
data
before starting the presentation let me
give you a quick outline of what i'll be
covering in my talk today firstly i will
be presenting the background and the
objectives of this presentation
next i will discuss the methodology that
will be adopted in order to achieve this
objective
moving on i will throw light on the
process of data collection data
pre-processing data analysis feature
creation feature engineering and
application of regression models
finally i will discuss some of the
results and analyze this
after it i will briefly talk about
future recommendations and references
and then conclude my presentation
so let us begin
now financial data forecasting has been
a field of great interest amongst
researchers across the world it is a
significant domain with a wide variety
of applications and consequences
moreover
every second massive amounts of
financial information is being generated
in the form of stock prices
cryptocurrency prices foreign exchange
indices
if this information is leveraged and
converted into insights it can be very
beneficial for both individuals and
business organizations this is because
it can potentially help one to a make
better operational and strategic
decisions
b to mitigate risks and losses and c to
generate some profits
now in order to achieve this objective
and facilitate the prediction of
financial data machine learning and deep
learning have been playing a very
crucial role
in the era a rapid technological
advancement machine learning and deep
learning for predicting stock market
prices and trends has become more
popular than ever before
in fact according to case studies by
deloitte and kpmg the growth rate of
intelligent systems and robo advisors
has been 70
with over 2.2 trillion dollars in assets
under management for such automated
predictive systems
thus financial data forecasting through
the means of machine learning and deep
learning forms the basis of my talk
today
the ultimate goal is to experiment and
evaluate different algorithms that give
the highest accuracy or the lowest error
this is achieved by exploring different
kinds of input variables that will be
used in our machine learning model and
seeing how much they contribute towards
stock price prediction
now the scope of the financial data that
i will be talking about today is time
series financial data of the stock
market so now some of you must be
wondering what exactly is time series
data it is nothing but the data
collected over repeated measurements of
time such as by the data or health
record data but it is sequential data
where the order of the data holds great
importance
now time c is forecasting of this data
facilitates the prediction of a value in
the future on the basis of the values in
the past
in order to achieve this objective a
structured methodology will be followed
this includes data collection data
pre-processing exploratory data analysis
feature engineering implementation of
machine learning algorithms as well as
testing of these algorithms now let us
cover each one of these steps of the
machine learning pipeline in some detail
now first comes data collection data
acts as fuel to any machine learning
model
thus it is imperative to collect large
amount of financial data
in this presentation i will be mainly
covering two kinds of financial data one
is numeric data that is the historical
stock prices and the other is the
non-numeric data which is the news
headlines
now numeric data or the stock price data
was collected because historic prices
and trends can potentially affect the
future prices and trends
so as we can see on my screen that uh 20
years of stock market data has been
collected with the help of yahoo finance
api
the structure of the data mainly
includes the date the high low open
close adjusted close and volume now
giving a little bit background about
what these symbols really mean the date
essentially acts as an index and tells
the date on which uh the data was
collected high denotes the
uh
highest value of the stock in a certain
day low denotes the lowest value of the
stock on a certain day open is the
opening price of the stock close is
naturally the closing price
volume is the amount of stock that a
company traded on a specific day
moving on some non-numeric data was also
collected now the main reason for
collecting non-numeric data was the fact
that on reading a lot of research papers
and on witnessing real life events i
realized that stock market data and the
future price of the stock are not only
dependent on the historic prices with a
number of other environmental factors
such as public sentiments social media
activities change in political powers
terrorist activities and so much more i
think great examples of this can be the
fact that certain tweets by eminent
personalities such as mark cuban or elon
musk often lead to the
increase or the decrease in the stock
prices
another great example would be the
sudden changes in the game stock prices
earlier this year because of some reddit
conversations this really motivated me
to collect
non-numeric data as well and this was
collected with the help of an api from
reuters.com which is
an online news agency that really covers
financial data the structure of this
data includes the headline the year in
which the headline was collected and the
date of the headline
now after we've collected a lot of data
it becomes very important to pre-process
it this is because the data can consist
uh some sort of null values or outliers
so uh for this presentation i would like
to cover missing values and to scale the
values
so um missing values can either be
completely removed or they can be
replaced with the mean uh other
median so i think it is not a very good
idea to completely remove null values
because uh simply removing them might
lead to some sort of risk of losing
important information whereas replacing
them will give more comprehensive
results
next the data was also scaled with the
help of a min max scaler in order to
standardize it
now that our data is collected and
pre-processed we come to the third stage
which is the process of conducting
exploratory data analysis
so this is a very important because it
facilitates better understanding of our
data set and we will speak about
plotting correlation tables graphs and
exploring the news articles to
understand them better
so now first comes
plotting a correlation table so what
exactly is correlation correlation
essentially provides a better
understanding about the dependence of
one variable on the other variable it
ranges from a scale of minus one to one
minus one essentially is perfectly
a negative correlation
zero indicates no correlation whereas
one indicates perfectly positive
correlation and essentially helps in
telling us the strength between various
features
so as we can see on the screen the
cooler colors which are the shades of
blue indicate less correlation whereas
the
heater colors the stronger colors which
are the shades of red depict the
stronger correlations
apart from this the closing prices of
the stock can also be plotted and
analyzed now as you can see on my screen
there are a lot of sharp peaks and dips
in the stock prices
um this is mainly because of some sort
of changes in the company it can also
happen because of other factors for
example in 2008 there was a financial
crisis in the united states which really
affected the stock markets not only in
the us but the rest of the world as well
so we can see that there's a constant
rise and dip in the prices over the
course of years because a lot of factors
which makes uh this entire uh topic so
very complex yet so very interesting
next uh in terms of the news headlines
the presence of competitive firms was
also analyzed and as we can see that
the competitor firms have been mentioned
a couple of times so i've taken the
example of bank of america and bank of
china so we can see jb morgan goldman
sachs
and wells fargo have been mentioned so
many times in the news articles
pertaining to bank of america whereas
icbc hsbc agricultural bank of china and
bea have been mentioned so many times in
headlines for bank of uh china stock
next i also plotted some word plots to
essentially understand what kind of
words have been consistently repeated uh
in the news articles and i've attached
some of the snapshots for your reference
as well
so now now that we understand our data
better and we've analyzed it by uh
plotting various graphs and charts uh it
is now time to create some additional
features so um a number of new features
can be created this includes technical
indicators sentiment scores subjectivity
scores and headline embeddings so now
these features will be used as input
variables in our machine learning model
in order to predict the closing price of
a certain stock or index in the future
now let's speak a little bit about
technical indicators these are
essentially mathematical calculations
that make use of past price and volume
to help in the prediction of stock
prices in the future
now various technical indicators can be
calculated and this includes simple
moving average exponential moving
average relative strength index and
moving average convergence divergence
so now um speaking about simple moving
average it is essentially a simple
average calculation of the closing price
of any security or stock for a given
number of days
exponential moving average assigns
lesser weight to the past data and it is
based on a recursive formula that
includes its
calculation all past days in our price
series
relative strength index calculated ratio
of the recent upward price movements to
the absolute price movements and finally
moving average convergence and
divergence reveals changes in the
strength direction momentum and duration
of a trend in a stocks prices
now tactical indicators and technical
analysis is generally based on a common
belief that price often
tends to repeat itself the trends often
uh in the past tend to follow each other
in the future and it also assumes that
the market discounts everything which
essentially means that the stock price
uh reflects everything that could
possibly affect a company
however in practice we know that this is
not true because of all the
environmental factors that have so much
uh impact on the stock prices
thus more features were created with the
help of news headlines this included
sentiment scores polarity scores and
headline embeddings
now um let's let's uh understand each of
these in a little bit more detail so now
first comes vader's sentiment intensity
analyzer which was made use of to
calculate the positive negative neutral
and compound scores as the name suggests
negative score tells us the negative
sentiment in a sentence neutral
indicates the neutral sentiment in a
sentence whereas positive tells us the
positive sentiment in a sentence a
compound score shows the aggregated
sentiment and it can also be calculated
with the help of vader's sentiment
intensity
analyzer now i'm sure some of you must
be wondering what is vader veda really
stands for balance aware dictionary and
sentiment reasoner it is a sentiment
analyzer that is trained using social
media data and news data using a lexicon
based approach
now don't worry if you don't understand
what a lexicon-based approach is it
essentially means that we look at the
words punctuation phases emojis and rate
them as positive or negative these
scores are based on pretend model
labeled by human reviewers
so the main advantage of using veda over
other analyzers is the fact that it is
computationally economic and very fast
the second advantage could be that it is
lexicon and the rules by vader are
directly accessible and not hidden
therefore it can be easily understood
extended and modified
next comes the use of text block which
is also a sentiment lexicon and used to
quantify the amount of personal opinion
and the amount of factual information it
gives us values of polarity and
subjectivity
now polarity essentially gives us the
idea if a statement is positive or
negative whereas subjectivity quantifies
the amount of personal opinion and the
factual information that is present in a
certain news article
lastly google's universal sentence
encoder is implemented we make use of it
to encode the textual data into high
dimensional vectors called embeddings
and these numerical representations of
the textual data the numerical vectors
generated can be made use of as features
in our predictive models
now uh i would like to also share a
little bit more about the basic
architecture of the universal sentence
encoder
what it really does is that it firstly
converts the sentences into lowercase
and then tokenizes them
next the encoder enables encoding of
sentences into fixed 512 dimension
embeddings or vectors
deep averaging network or dan is the
encoder that is made use of here it
computes the unigram and the bigram
embeddings and averages out these
embeddings and passes them on to a deep
neural network
then it returns a final sentence of
bedding of 512 dimensions
these embeddings are used for
unsupervised and supervised tasks in the
stanford natural language interface
corpus
the model can then be used to map any
sentence into a sentence embedding of
512 dimensions
now that we've created so many new
features let us move on to the next step
which is feature engineering
this is a very crucial step in the
machine learning pipeline
so uh as a part of feature engineering
mainly two things are carried out
dimension that
reduction and feature selection
now dimensionality reduction is
performed using principal component
analysis
what pci actually does is that it
reduces the computational complexity and
helps to avoid the curse of
dimensionality in pca the data is
projected onto principal components such
that the maximum variance is preserved
and least amount of information is lost
in the process
as you can see in the graph on my screen
uh the number of components versus the
cumulative xp variance is plotted and we
can see that the maximum variance is
preserved by using 150 components
thus we can reduce the dimensionality of
the data set to 150 by projecting it
onto the hyper clean defined by the
first 150 principal components
next we perform feature selection using
recursive feature elimination
now in rfe a backward selection of
features is implemented based on two
attributes
one is the coefficient and the other one
is the feature importance the main aim
of feature selection is to choose a
subset of features from the original
input data set such that the subset is
able to represent the entire input data
set while at the same time reduces the
potential impacts of noise or irrelevant
variables and thus reduces complexity
so now it's quite intuitive that not all
features would be affecting uh the price
in the future with equal importance this
was confirmed when rfe was performed and
it was noted that some features such as
simple moving average exponential moving
average and positive scores contributed
significantly while the others did not
now we've performed a lot of crucial
steps in the machine learning pipeline
and we come to the main chunk which is
the actual implementation of machine
learning and deep learning models
so a regression based approach is uh
followed to predict the price in the
future and as a consequence of that
predict the movement of the stock prices
as well
so initially i tried a couple of
classification algorithms such as random
forests support vector machines logistic
regression but i realized that these
models often do not give a very high
accuracy and
result in overfitting so many times
thus i uh stuck with the regression
based approach with the help
of long short-term memory so now this is
a very very popular type of
algorithm that has gained a lot of
popularity mainly because of the fact
that it is very successful on time
series data this is mainly because it
can handle long-term dependencies very
well
lstm is a special type of rnn actually
and in lstm small altercations can be
made to the information with the help of
operations such as multiplication and
addition and this information flows
through various cell states
as a result lscm can selectively
remember or forget information based on
their importance the sigmoid neutral
network layer and the multiplication
point wise function help in deciding
which information is let through
so i hope you have a
high level understanding of what 3d lstm
is and now let's dive a little deeper
and discuss the architecture of the lstm
model
so firstly it includes an activation
function which was chosen as a linear
activation function
the loss function is the mean squared
error whereas the optimizer is the adam
optimizer with the 0.01 learning rate uh
these parameters were essentially uh
deviced after carrying out a lot of
experimentation
in lstm there is also a very important
parameter called the sequence length
which determines the number of days in
the past to consider to predict the
value in the future
now various experimentations were
conducted with different input features
in the model and they were evaluated on
the basis of a root mean square error or
rmse scores
then these four parameters that we have
were optimized with the help of keras
random search in order to optimize them
and i would discuss the results in the
later subsections of the presentation
then like in any task that we perform
testing holds so much value
in time series data back testing uh is
actually the equivalent of cross
validation for other kinds of data and
uh backtesting essentially is an attempt
to bootstrap the data in a way that um
we can estimate the expected test error
and uh we cannot simply use
cross-validation because the data has a
sequence and this sequence holds
importance so the notion of bad testing
essentially refers to the process of
assessing the accuracy of the historic
data
now after performing back testing uh
let's now discuss some of the results
and analyze these results to better
understand how this was beneficial for
us and what we can do to improve
so now uh we can see on my screen that
i've plotted the actual versus predicted
values of the closing price after
implementation of machine learning
so here if you look closely the value of
the predicted stock actually differs
from the actual value however we can see
that the movement of the price is the
same and
i think that's that's also a great
achievement in the sense that we were at
least able to predict the movement uh to
a great extent extent with the help of
lstm
next different combinations of input
variables were experimented and
evaluated so the graph that you see on
my screen essentially um speaks about
the rmse scores using different input
variables so we can see that if we only
use technical indicators as our input in
the
machine learning and deep learning
models then our error is quite high
however if we combine it with the raw
features then the error naturally
decreases
another very important point to note
here is that the features that were
selected after performing feature
engineering uh contributed to the least
possible error which proves that feature
engineering is a very important aspect
of the machine learning and deep
learning models and performing it yields
better results in the future
next we also have the results before and
after optimization once you perform
optimization we can see that there is a
reduction in the error and our model
tends to perform better so
optimization should also be performed in
order to achieve better results
this brings me to the next stage of my
presentation which is future
recommendations the application of
machine learning and deep learning can
be made in the financial industry and
can be expanded to many more aspects
such as sanction screening fraud
detection anti-money laundering checks
and kyc processes
other than this topological data
analysis can also be made use of and
this is a relatively new approach and
has been in the limelight in the recent
few months because of its success in
medical imaging so i think it's going to
be very interesting to see how it
performs on stock market data
and this brings me to the end of my
presentation through the course of the
presentation the relevance and
importance of financial data forecaster
has been noted and we have gone through
the entire pipeline of how the data was
collected through yahoo finance api and
reuters.com
next the data was pre-processed and
missing values were
checked for
then we analyzed the data by plotting a
number of graphs correlation tables some
other charts to better understand it
then a number of features were created
in addition to the raw features that we
had collected such as technical
indicators sentiment scores and
embeddings after we collected it we
performed feature engineering with the
help of principal component analysis and
recursive feature elimination
after this we performed a long shorter
memory algorithm on the data and
calculated the rmse scores we then
tested our algorithm and also optimized
it and we discovered that feature
engineering is extremely important we
noted that optimization of hyper
parameters is very important
and we also understood the fact that
stock market data not only depends on
previous prices but a lot of other
environmental factors that need to be
taken into account such as political
agendas terrorist activities economic
fluctuations recessions social media
activities and so much more
here's also a list of all the references
and all the research papers i read in
order to gain more knowledge of the
stock market and how financial data
forecasting can be really performed and
at the end i would like to say that
thank you so much for your time and for
attending this talk i hope this
presentation has been
uh knowledgeable in informative with
those who want to delve into machine
learning i had a great time presenting
at pycon and i'm so glad to get the
opportunity to do so
if there are any questions i'd be happy
to take them otherwise you can reach out
to me on any of these channels